from NASA's Kennedy Space Center in
Florida you're watching live coverage of
the Parker Solar Probe mission to unlock
mysteries of the sun's atmosphere good
morning i'm nasa's marine lewis thanks
for waking up early this Sunday morning
for our second launch attempt we have
team coverage of today's launch from
NASA story McClendon at a viewing area
near the iconic Vehicle Assembly
Building NASA edges franklin Fitzgerald
and Blair Allen and NASA's Josh Finch
and Mick Waltman at the mission director
Center
we'll have in-depth interviews on
everything you need to know about Parker
Solar Probe and how the weather is
shaping up but first
Parker Solar Probe is targeted to launch
at 3:31 this morning Eastern Time from
launch complex 37 at Cape Canaveral Air
Force Station the launch window is 65
minutes long
Parker will take off on a United Launch
Alliance Delta 4 heavy rocket speeding
up to four hundred thirty thousand miles
per hour in orbit that's fast enough to
get from Philadelphia to Washington DC
in just one second it will travel seven
times closer to the Sun than any
spacecraft before Parker will help us
understand how the Sun affects weather
in space so why is the space weather
important first a little background
Parker Solar Probe is named after dr.
Eugene Parker a physicist who figured
out 60 years ago that our star actually
has its own wind and storms and they can
spread far into space this space weather
can disrupt communication signals from
our satellites and even caused power
outages on earth besides impacts here on
the ground we also need to understand
solar wind to help us explore deeper
into space just as ocean explorers need
to understand currents NASA needs to
understand space weather to help us send
astronauts to the moon Mars and other
distant destinations scientists have
sought answers about space weather for
more than 60 years and will send Park
in two temperatures of 2500 degrees
Fahrenheit to find them coming up we'll
find out how Parker will manage to get
so close to our star without burning up
but first we are now about 28 minutes
from launch so let's check in with
NASA's Josh Finch and Mick Waltman and
Kennedy's mission director Center for an
update hi guys good morning Murray I'm
Joshua Finch and I'm here with Mick
Waltman good morning Mick
good morning Josh I'm happy to be here
on behalf of NASA's launch services
program and we're happy to have you this
is our second launch attempt for NASA's
Parker Solar Probe on the Delta 4 can
you tell us a little bit about yesterday
why we scrubbed in what happened right
after that yeah absolutely a lot of
works going on by the launch team since
yesterday's launch attempt they've been
working on a few things the gaseous
helium bottle pressure limit that
resulted in yesterday's morning scrub
was evaluated by a United Launch
Alliance and the NASA launch teams for
today's op the teams will continue to
monitor that limit however they did
place in some new limits for the port
and starboard common booster cores so
they'll continue to watch that today
after D tanking yesterday the team did
perform inspections of the launch
vehicle bond on foam insulation or Bo
fee due to the cold temperatures
achieved during cryogenic tanking
yesterday minor repairs were required in
some of the interface areas they made
those repairs verified them this morning
they're ready to support today's launch
tanking operations and then we began
with moving the MST earlier today to get
ready for a launch early this morning
and you can see that MST our mobile
service tower standing behind the Delta
for heavy rocket on the screen the teams
also just received a weather briefing
from the US Air Force at 45th Space Wing
the launch weather officer for today's
mission is looking into a whole host of
weather related details such as wind
speed cloud coverage and more and launch
teams need to know this before
committing to launch that report came
back pretty great our probability of
violation is now just 5% that means we
are 95% go when's 6 knots out of the
southwest the temperature is at about 78
degrees those concerns that we were
initially looking at with the anvil
clouds it doesn't look like any of them
are going to drift into the
launch area today so we are really good
on cloud coverage for today so a good
news story with the weather improving
for us and Mick can you tell us a little
bit about the Delta for heavy with the
additional third stage that we're seeing
on our screen now yeah absolutely Josh
you know due to the extremely high
energy required for this mission
the Delta for heavy launch vehicle was
chosen by United Launch Alliance and
NASA LSP the launch vehicle is unique in
the fact that it has three first stage
hydrogen fueled common booster cores
each have an RS 68 a main engine to
provide the initial thrust out of
Earth's atmosphere on top of the center
common booster core you have a delta
cryogenic second stage with an RL 10 B
engine which is used to achieve an
intermediate escape orbit once in space
on top of that we have a 63 foot 5 meter
by sector composite fairing which
protects Parker Solar Probe as it
ascends through Earth's atmosphere on
its way to space and inside the fairing
along with the Parker Solar Probe
spacecraft we have a third stage
provided by Northrop Grumman innovation
systems a solid rocket motor that is
called the star 48 BV it's a Vectra bowl
motor that's used to put that final push
to send Parker Solar Probe on its
trajectory to the Sun all of these
vehicle features play an important role
in getting Parker Solar Probe on its way
to touch the Sun this morning and again
a live shot there of the delta 4 heavy
rocket with the additional third stage
at Space Launch Complex 37 and make
we've been sitting here in the mission
directors Center listening in to the
launch teams can you give me an update
on on what's happened so far in today's
countdown yeah so far the teams have
proceeded through the launch count
launch conductor Scott Barney has
orchestrated all launch steps with the
launch teams to get the cryogenic
loading done on first stage and second
stage
teams have finished that off and our
maintaining and topping the stage is
currently right now so a lot going on
here as we move toward a liftoff at 3:30
1:00 a.m. we are inside of a built-in
hold at the moment but we'll continue to
monitor the countdown here the mission
directors Center
but for now I'll go back to Murray for
more on NASA's Parker Solar Probe all
right thanks guys Parker Solar Probe
will
travel very far very fast to get closer
to the Sun than any spacecraft before
NASA's Jessica Londa helps put it in
perspective launch of Parker Solar Probe
is just the first step let's talk about
what it's going to do on its own in
space
did you know our models for predicting
what our star is going to do are
incomplete we can't fully understand the
sun's physics if we've never been there
here's how Parker plans to change the
game first it's going to get up close
and personal find just four million
miles away from the surface and that may
not sound so close to you but if we put
her and the Sun on either side of a
football field Parker is going to tuck
and run all the way to the 4 yard line
where temperatures can reach a million
degrees Fahrenheit but don't worry
Parker's equipped to handle those types
of temperatures and it will use just a
single gallon of ordinary water to do it
if you can believe it the spacecraft's
thermal regulation system is designed to
collect and dissipate heat just like a
car radiator that way we can stay where
the action is orbiting the Sun's corona
in order to figure out why it's even
hotter than the surface so but the
corona isn't just harmful to our probe
it's dangerous for us as well that's
because of a little something called the
solar wind discovered by none other than
our spacecraft namesake Helio physicist
Jean Parker the solar winds to use
harmful solar particles way beyond Pluto
and no one knows exactly what
accelerates it so far so fast
that's why Parker is designed to hang
out near the origin of this wind so we
can finally figure out what it's doing
and what it could potentially do to her
thanks Jessica
data collected by Parker Solar Probe
will provide an unprecedented picture of
the Sun NASA edges Franklin Fitzgerald
is live on set right now with senior
Helio physicist Eric Christian hi
Franklin hi Murray
now Eric you're the deputy principal
investigator for the ISA suite of
instruments on Parker Solar Probe tell
us what those instruments are going to
be used for so the easiest instruments
study solar energetic particles the
highest energy particles coming from the
Sun these are pieces of atoms that are
moving at up to a half the speed of
light and they're important they're one
of the three science questions for
Parker's Solar Probe these are the
particles that can actually damage
spacecraft and even be in danger to
astronauts now you said there's one of
the questions that Parker's Solar Probe
was gonna be looking at what are the
other two so the other two questions are
why is the corona hotter than the
surface of the Sun that seems really
weird normally when you get further from
a fire you get colder the corona is
millions of degrees whereas the surface
of the Sun there's only thousands of
degrees how that happens we're gonna go
to where the action is and figure that
out
the third question is how is the solar
wind the stream of particles that the
Sun blows out in all directions
all the time how is that accelerated up
to a million miles an hour again from
Earth we can't figure that out it's all
been smeared out 93 million miles away
by going close to the Sun we can be
where it's happening and actually
measure why the solar wind is being
accelerated and actually Parker Solar
Probe is actually going to be looking at
the origin of space weather where the
solar winds and space weather begins
that's right so we're trying to do some
basic science that'll be able to get us
to the point where we can do models that
predict space weather which is what our
eventual goal is in on the earth
terrestrial weather they're doing much
better now on predictions and that's
because they have these really
complicated atmospheric models but they
needed to do some basic science on how
winds affect
wins at other altitudes how hurricanes
move you know and all that basic science
was needed before they could do the
models we're doing the basic science for
space weather models Eric thank you for
your help this evening and I'm sure
you're gonna go find a spot to see the
launch this evening I'm really excited
about it all right Marie back to you all
right thanks Franklin
let's check in now with Josh and Mick in
the mission director Center for an
update and a closer look at the Delta
for heavy one of the world's most
powerful rockets guys Thank You Murray
and welcome back to the mission director
Center it takes a team to be able to
launch the delta 4 heavy this evening
teams from NASA United Launch Alliance
the US Air Force and more MIT can you
characterize the teamwork that goes into
doing something like this tonight
yes Josh you said it's a it's a team
effort to get a mission this far
prepared for launch mission teams
working around the country have prepared
the rocket and the spacecraft for this
morning's launch attempt teams from
United Launch Alliance stationed in
Denver Colorado from their production
and manufacturing facility in Decatur
Alabama we have spacecraft from NASA's
Goddard Space Flight Center in Greenbelt
Maryland John Hopkins Applied Physics
lab in Laurel Maryland and of course
right here in Florida the team worked on
the spacecraft at Astro tech in
Titusville and here at Cape Canaveral
Air Force Station inside the mission
director Center at hangar AE and the
Delta Operations Center and that's a
live shot inside the Delta Operations
Center that we just saw there where the
NASA launch manager Omar Baez and the
launch director Luo man Jerry from
United Launch Alliance are working with
teams sort of liftoff the day of the
delta 4 heavy earlier in the countdown
the team received a weather briefing
from the Air Force which improved the
weather forecast to 95 percent go only a
5% probability of violation but the US
Air Force not only briefs the launch
teams of weather which could impact a
lot but they also keep the launch teams
aware of other launch considerations on
the eastern range including telemetry
coverage for public safety and they
update the teams on colas make can you
talk about colas yeah your reference to
colas or collision avoidance analysis
which is performed by you know
States Air Force for public safety and
the rocket safety actually one of the
considerations they analyze is objects
in space for example other satellites
around the earth that could be in the
flight path of the delta 4 heavy this
morning with a 65 minute window that
today there could be some small cutouts
what we refer to where the launch teams
would not be able to lift off this
analysis has started days out the final
report is provided to the launch manager
Omar Baez on the day of launch to help
determine today's t0 for the launch
attempt we've heard there's no Cola
cutouts for today's launch attempt so
we're still on schedule for a 331 a.m.
launch and we do have an hour and
five-minute window should launch teams
need more time
but worth at the beginning of the window
right now you're looking at live shots
of the delta 4 heavy rocket and mick can
you tell us a little bit more about
about what's happened up to this point
yeah right now we're in the t-minus four
and holding we've got about 12 and a
half minutes left in this built-in hold
teams have been working to get cryogenic
tanking completed those operations are
finishing up with topping and
maintaining continuing things were
progressing towards that 331 a.m.
liftoff as I mentioned before we do have
that 65 minute or hour and 5 minute
window that you had talked about for
tonight's launch attempt in case
something does come up but right now all
things are go and looking good for a
on-time liftoff at 3:30 1:00 a.m. so
what's going on here in the mission
directors Center and we'll keep
listening into the launch teams as they
prepare for a liftoff but for now we'll
go back to Murray alright thank you
gentlemen
NASA's Torey McClendon is standing by
live at one of our launch viewing areas
with one of NASA's senior leaders dr.
Thomas zur Buchan Torey thanks Murray
dr. subbu ken as head of NASA's science
Mission Directorate helped us understand
why this mission was selected and why we
need to study our Sun Wow how this
mission has been a long time coming you
know that for 60 years we tried to do
this mission and it was selected finally
because we had a mission that actually
is feasible and viable so we had the
technologies to protect a spacecraft
from the heat
and we had a mission that was fitting
into our budget so we're ready to go
with this Park Isola broke so talking
about going back 60 years this is the
first time ever that NASA has named a
spacecraft after a living person dr.
eugene Parker can you talk about that
decision oh yes I was so excited to be
able to call him and tell him hey can we
name a spacecraft after you and it's
like yes that I will be fine you know
it's the only name that really fits
there first of all he is the guy who
came up with solar wind as a theoretical
theoretical concept before it was found
and observed and in space it's also true
that his theories are really at the
heart of 35 of our missions of our
hundred and seven missions in science
and so it's just an incredible impact
he's had so his name belongs there
well what about talk about NASA's living
with a star program and how this mission
fits into that living with a star is
important part of heliophysics overall
so the mission of course thus
fundamental science it looks at the
atmosphere of our star and with it the
atmosphere of stars everywhere this is
our rosetta stone our Sun is our rosetta
stone what's also our star in a sense
that it's the source of space sweater
and living with a star of course it's
focused very much on understanding space
weather really what the impact is of
these emissions on our technological
societies the systems in space and on
the ground that are affected by these
perturbations that come are coming down
but we're definitely looking forward to
the launch this morning and you'll be
watching with dr. Parker himself
I hear absolutely I look forward to
being right there with him and and I
want to look at him when it you know
this rocket goes out there great well
with that I think we'll go back to you
Murray all right thank you
Parker Solar Probe will set off to soak
up the Sun in about 14 minutes but it's
already had quite the journey here's a
look at the months of work that led to
this moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for those of you just joining us you're
looking at a live view of Parker Solar
Probe poised on the launchpad ready to
lift off in just about 12 minutes on a
journey to kiss the Sun and unlock its
mysteries
I'm NASA's Murray Lewis Parker Solar
Probe is targeted to launch at 3:31 this
morning Eastern Time from launch complex
37 at Cape Canaveral Air Force Station
in Florida the launch window will be
open for 65 minutes
Parker will take off on a United Launch
Alliance Delta 4 heavy rocket speeding
up to four hundred thirty thousand miles
per hour in orbit that's fast enough to
get from Philadelphia to Washington DC
in just one second it will travel seven
times closer to the Sun than any
spacecraft before Parker will help us
understand how the Sun affects weather
in space and that space weather is
important first a little background why
Parker Solar Probe is named after dr.
Eugene Parker a physicist who figured
out 60 years ago that our star actually
has its own wind and storms and they can
spread far into space this space weather
can disrupt communication signals from
our satellites and even caused power
outages on earth besides impacts here on
the ground we also need to understand
solar wind to help us explore deeper
into space just as ocean explorers need
to understand currents NASA needs to
understand space weather to help us send
astronauts to the moon Mars and other
distant destinations scientists have
sought answers about space weather for
more than 60 years and will send Parker
in to temperatures of 2,500 degrees
Fahrenheit to find them we are now about
10 minutes from liftoff so let's go over
to the mission director Center for an
update from United Launch Alliance and
then
Josh will take us through the count Josh
Thank You Murray and I'm being joined by
Elissa Macbeth of United Launch Alliance
good morning Alisa good morning thank
you for being with us yeah we first have
the video of the Delta for an animation
taking off and what's going to happen at
team on is zero if we could roll the
video three Delta four rs-68 a main
engines ignite and generate more than
2.1 million pounds of thrust to lift the
rocket away from the pad the Delta 4
reaches Mach 1 the speed of sound at 1
minute 18 seconds at 3 minutes 56
seconds the port and starboard booster
engines shut down two seconds later the
boosters are jettisoned at 5 minutes 36
seconds propellant levels deplete and a
main engine shuts down seven seconds
later the Delta Force separation system
activates to release the first stage at
5 minutes 55 seconds
the first Delta cryogenic second stage
or DCSS main engine burn begins at
approximately 6 minutes 5 seconds the
payload fairing is jettisoned at 10
minutes 37 seconds cut off of the DCSS
engine or Miko one occurs at 22 minutes
25 seconds the DCSS main engine has
restarted for the second burn
approximately 14 minutes later second
cut off of the DCSS main engine occurs
following a 30 second Coast phase the
third stage is separated
20 seconds later the third stage is
ignited approximately one minute 29
seconds later burnout of the third stage
solid rocket motor occurs at 43 minutes
10 seconds
the third stage releases NASA's Parker's
Solar Probe spacecraft on its journey to
the Sun Alisa a lot happens after t0 but
can you tell me what's happened up to
this point and what's about to happen in
the count
yeah so we're the rocket is ready to go
at this point it's fueled the people on
console are all their systems have been
checked out and are ready to go and
we're about to enter into a terminal
count poll conducted by the launch
conductor where the launch conductor
will pull each engineer and verify that
their systems are in fact ready with a
simple go and that indicates that the
launch is ready and Delta's ready to fly
and we're just about 18 seconds away
from that poll live on your screen you
can see the delta 4 heavy rocket with
the additional third stage at Space
Launch Complex 37 I Cape Canaveral Air
Force Station and we'll listen in to
this poll in about five seconds status
check to proceed with terminal count
first aid systems propulsion go
hydraulics go rocks go LH to go second
stage systems logs go LH to go third
stage systems there's a [ __ ] vehicle
manager go electrical systems airborne
go ground go facility go RF STS go
flight control go comm go Jacek you know
operations support go pneumatics go
umbilicals go has gas go ACS go redline
monitor go quality go op safety manager
go you're all a safety officer go
vehicle system engineer go anomaly chief
go
coordinator clear to proceed launch
director you have permission to launch
proceeding with the count and make you
establish swingarm lock pins pull active
and we just heard the poll with all
stations reporting that there go for
launch
Alissa we're entering the final few
minutes of the count here about 5
minutes and 45 seconds before we launch
and can you tell me what it means to
United Launch Alliance to be able to
launch the Parker Solar Probe mission
yeah
ula is always excited about doing
interplanetary missions the chance to
get to explore the solar system is
something that we look forward to and
are happy to be a part of this mission
means a lot to us is Delta heavy so
Delta heavy gets to show off its
performance and get Parker Solar Probe
exactly where it needs to go which is
the only rocket currently that can can
do that so we're excited to be a part of
that yeah well thank you very much for
being with us and enjoy the launch today
thank you you as well thank you
Oh minus 5 minutes ovm transfer a third
stage to internal power
Roger all steps are complete prior to
terminal count
and we have about 30 seconds remaining
and our hold in the team - clock after
that the L - and the team - clocks will
be synced up you're looking at a live
shot the delta 4 heavy rocket poised for
liftoff from Space Launch Complex 37 at
Cape Canaveral Air Force Station
pick up the count five four three - one
two - four minutes and Counting
- 355 ground Pyro's enabled
and once again 25 we're about three
minutes and 20 seconds before liftoff
I'm it can you tell me what we have left
to go in the next three minutes
yeah the teams are securing locks and
llh to liquid hydrogen tank in there
they'll be finishing that up getting
ready to go internal you'll hear a call
for spacecraft power to internal they'll
be arming their flight termination
systems and getting ready for launch and
then bringing the delta 4 heavy launch
vehicle onto internal power to prepare
for the final terminal panel - - 49 and
we are coming up very shortly on the
verification spacecraft being on
internal CBC locks at flight pressure
and flight level - 230 and SC verify
spacecraft on internal power verified
and we are t-minus two minutes five
seconds and counting after lifting off
we'll be listening to the voice of
United Launch Alliance Patrick Moore
providing acent commentary 155 launch
sequence or start
- 140 FCS launched enable 137 CBC lh2 at
flight pressure and flight level FPS
armed - 120 will see you are SCS count
started - - one minute
engine starts go rock report range
status Ranger in 50 lb o LC o BM there's
always go for launch
range is selected stairs LH to secure
fly level 40
- 30 status check go Delta go PSP - 15
brophy ignition ten nine mr. star eight
seven six five three two one zero
liftoff of the mighty delta 4 heavy
rocket with NASA's Parker Solar Probe a
daring mission to shed light on the
mysteries of our closest star the Sun
our education look good in the full
dress code
25 seconds into flight can you look good
on all three booster
35 second kid
pressure on the port booster throttling
down to the partial thrust mode response
looks good
I'm fifty seconds into flight strap-on
boosters look good in the full thrust
mode core booster looks good in the
partial thrust mode
at one minute light eagle trajectory
looking good right down the middle
racetrack
one minute ten seconds into flight way
up on one minute 19 seconds into flight
max Q maximum dynamic pressure and Mach
1 l fours now supersonic one minute
thirty seconds into flight
Gordon starboard booster engines
continue look good in the full thrust
mode before booster looks good Marshall
thrust mode one minute 45 seconds into
flight trajectory continuing to look
good right down the middle the range
track ACS press valve has been opened
ACS pressure response looks good two
minutes ten seconds in strap-on boosters
continue to look good in the full thrust
mode core booster looks good in the
partial thrust mode and Delta four has
gone to close loop guidance two minutes
thirty seconds into flight
and at 2 minutes 39 seconds into flight
the Delta 4 rocket now weighs just one
half of what it did at launch burning
propellant at a rate of almost 5,000
pounds per second and launch vehicle is
now 33 miles in altitude 49 miles
downrange distance traveling at 4,500
miles per hour 3 minutes into flight our
68a engines in the port and starboard
boosters continue look good in the full
thrust mode core booster looks good in
the partial thrust mode 3 minutes 15
seconds into flight
projector eight continuing to look good
down the middle of the range track
approximately two minutes remaining the
boost stage of flight chamber pressures
continuing to look good on all three
boosters Orton starboard booster in the
full thrust mode core booster continuing
in the partial thrust mode and standing
by for a strap-on booster throttle down
momentary port and starboard boosters
have begun to throttle down and we have
jettison of both strap-on boosters core
booster has throttled back up to full
thrust response looks good
four minutes 25 seconds into flight
upper-stage lock system has begun blue
states chill down sequence and one
minute remaining in boost phase of
flight an upper stage fuel system has
begun blue states Hill down
five minutes into flight just over 30
seconds now remaining in first aid first
stage phase of flight core booster
engine continues to look good in the
full thrust mode the equal trajectory
continuing down the middle to Reince
track 5 minutes 20 seconds into flight
and standing by for core booster
throttle down momentarily core booster
has begun to throttle down standing by
for Pico and we have Beco booster engine
cutoff standing by for stage step and we
have good indication of stage separation
edges deploying it pre start on the all
10 and we have ignition on the air all
10 engine engine chamber pressure looks
good
and we have good indication of payload
fairing jettison now six minutes 20
seconds into flight and with the boost
phase of flight complete Parker Solar
Probe will now continue its journey to
the Sun
and at 6 minutes 50 seconds into flight
rl10 chamber pressure looks good seeing
good responses on the upper stage RCS
system and after a brief review of
booster performance seeing very close to
nominal performance on the booster
and this first burn of the second-stage
will last approximately four minutes 42
seconds now seven minutes thirty seconds
into flight about three minutes
remaining in the first burn
and at eight minutes 30 seconds into
flight Carlton chamber pressure
continues to look good seeing very
stable values on the upper stage locks
and elites to tanks HDS storage bottle
pressure looks good and vehicle body
rates are very smooth
now nine minutes into flight
at nine minutes forty seconds into
flight just under one minute remaining
now in the first burn of the second
stage second stage continuing to perform
nominally Carleton engine performing
well tank pressures look good
equal body rates remain smooth and then
it's into flight
and about 30 seconds remaining in the
first burn
and standing by for Miko one momentarily
and we have Miko
body rates smoothing out nicely and now
seeing upper stage ACS firing judge
expected now eleven minutes into flight
and this will be approximately a 13
minute coaster ation prior to mess too
from the mission director center I'm
joined once again by Elissa Macbeth if
United Launch Alliance for those of you
that are watching we had an on-time
liftoff today at the Delta for a heavy
rocket and Alisa can you tell me how the
launch 1 oh my goodness that was a
beautiful launch just the sound and
everything oh it was great
it's looking good so far - we saw good
separation of the Boosters from the main
core and the booster from the second
stage just experienced Miko one there
there's going to be two burns of the
second stage so that's coming up the
second burn second engine start
and then in just 40 approximately 45
minutes we'll see the payload separation
so everything's looking good so far
great now you can you tell me a little
bit about about about your experience
working with ula and and what it's like
to work in Mission like this again yeah
so I get to I get to work with the the
innards of the rocket the electronics
the avionics boxes ordnance pyrotechnics
all that kinds of stuff so working on a
mission like this is something really
special to be able to get your hands on
on on a vehicle like this and do
something that's going to affect the
world is really really amazing well
thank you very much again for being with
us and I think we'll talk to you a
little bit later in the broadcast
Thank You Alyssa sounds good thanks
and at 13 minutes into flight delta for
upper-stage is continuing the coast
period prior to ms two vehicle systems
all performing nominally during this
cousine periodic thruster firings as
expected tank pressures and body rates
remain stable
and a brief review of the performance
from the first burn seeing a fairly
close correlation on major orbital
elements performance appears to be
pretty good
from the mission director center once
again we had an on-time liftoff of the
delta 4 heavy rocket on your screen you
were seeing a live telemetry view
animation of the rocket on its flight
path so things are looking pretty good
at this moment as we're in a Coast phase
right now and we'll go back to Marie
Louis for more on NASA's Parker Solar
Probe Marie
all right thanks Josh and I don't know
about you but here in the studio we
could feel the rocket Rumble and I know
for our folks here on the TV side that
never gets old we have Tory standing by
now with a very special guest we've been
talking about him the whole show and
Tory we can't wait to meet him
please introduce us thanks Marie I do
certainly have a very special guest with
me dr. Eugene Parker himself dr. Parker
you just watched the launch of the
mission that bears your name what was
that like well I really have to turn
from biting my nails and getting it
launched to thinking about all the
interesting things which I don't know
yet
and which will be made clear I assume
over the next five or six or seven years
it's a whole new phase and it's going to
be fascinating throughout I'm
anticipating that the results will turn
up basic information on why the corona
of the Sun is at a million degrees that
accounts for the acceleration of the
solar wind waiting for the data now on
the experts can get busy and sorted out
[Music]
all I can say is Wow here we go we're
interpersonal learning and over the next
several years that's right so we'll
definitely be anxiously awaiting that
data and research I also hear that this
is the very first launch that you were
able to witness with your own eyes is
that right that's right so the video of
course is supplied all of us with you
my rocket launches but somehow when
you're looking at the real thing it's
quite quite impressive nothing compares
to the real thing I would think yeah
it's a little like the Taj Mahal we've
all seen pictures of the building and
what a graceful structure it is but if
you happen to be in India and they stop
by that way there's the real thing and
video paintings and so forth just don't
catch it somehow your mind is in a
different state well we are certainly
all honored to have you here with it
this morning thank you so much for
joining us my pleasure
Murray we'll go back to you all right
thanks Tory so great to have him here on
the show understanding the Sun will give
us valuable information for future space
missions my Chris kovitch from Johns
Hopkins Applied Physics Laboratory is
live on set now with NASA edges Blair
Allen Blair
thanks so much Murray listen I gotta say
I'm very excited but I want to know did
you get out and see the launch witness
at first hand oh yeah I'm really excited
I had to run outside then there was
absolutely beautiful night the
shockwaves rolling over you the
beautiful sight of those three boosters
rolling in we could see it a long way we
could actually see the the burnout which
was at about t plus 4 minutes so really
exciting night now what you work with
primarily at the Applied Physics
Laboratory is space exploration how does
a mission like this we know the valuable
science that it's going to get but how
does this help other missions and with
regard to space exploration well this is
gonna be a really big deal not just for
space exploration but people on earth
you're gonna we're gonna get a lot of
new knowledge which is going to help
predictions and warnings of severe solar
events that can take down the power grid
or other pieces of our technological
society and then as we go ever more
further into space
robotic Li or human it's important to be
able to get better forecasts and
warnings for the operators of the
robotic spacecraft and the people that
go there it's today we're kind of like
the Mariners were in
a few hundred years ago or you didn't
get warnings of hurricanes and we want
to be able to provide those warnings so
we gave people and hardware safe yeah
exactly keeping our hardware safe and
all those future missions we haven't
even some of our current missions we'll
be able to help them as well yes no
doubt you know we're try to design to
withstand the harshest environment but
it's always worthwhile to have a good
warning and know when you got to hunker
down and play things safe until the
storm blows over so to speak exactly why
I appreciate it thanks so much for
coming off console to be with us for a
few minutes and answer some questions we
look forward to getting great things
from Parker Solar Probe thanks we look
forward to it too you know we got our
starting line and a finish line finish
line for the development team and the
launch team and the starting line for
the science team for seven years of
discovery so awesome yep back to you
Murray
alright thanks Blair so how do we get
close enough to the Sun to actually
sample it's incredibly hot atmosphere
it's complicated
but NASA's Tory McClendon caught up with
dr. Nikki Fox project scientist for this
mission to help illustrate Parker's path
thanks Murray Nikki thank you for being
here you're welcome so there's so many
fascinating things about this mission
one thing that I find particularly
interesting is the unusual orbit that
Parker's going to take once it launches
can you explain that yes once we're in
space it's a very busy first couple of
weeks for us we have to get it
commissioned and all ready to go because
just six weeks after launch we encounter
the planet Venus for the first time we
use Venus to give us a little gravity
assist basically it's like a little
handbrake turn and it focuses our orbit
in towards the Sun because we don't want
to be dragged around in any way or
influenced by the Earth's orbit and so
during our 24 orbits of our seven year
mission we actually will do these flybys
of Venus another six times and each time
as you can see from this animation our
orbit is getting smaller and smaller
until those final three orbits we are at
our final closest approach speaking of
closest approach can you describe
exactly how close the parker Solar Probe
spacecraft is going to get to the fun
yes at our closest approach we will be
three point eight three million miles
above the Sun surface and I
that you just thought million that
doesn't sound very close but you know
the earth and the Sun are 93 million
miles apart and so if I put the earth in
the Sun in the end zones of a football
field parka Solar Probe would tuck and
run all the way to the Suns four yard
line well in the red zone knocking on
the door for a touchdown right by that
goal line
well that sounds extremely close to me
so I'm sure that folks are now wondering
how is a spacecraft not going to burn up
at the 40-yard line
we have a wonderful heat shield that we
keep oriented between us and the Sun and
so it keeps everything in the main body
of the spacecraft
nice and cool it kind of creates a
shadow and it has a white coating on it
that was specially designed for Parker
Solar Probe very much like you prefer to
be in a white car on a hot day instead
of a black car on a hot day the heat
shield is glowing and it is reflecting a
lot of the sun's energy and so the front
side of the heat shield gets to about
2,500 degrees Fahrenheit but everything
on the main body in that shadow is it
about 85 degrees Fahrenheit so much like
a pleasant Florida even that sounds so
lovely well Nikki thank you so much for
being here today we're all extremely
excited about this mission go Parker
Solar Probe and with that Mergui we'll
go back to you we are coming up on
another major milestone in Parker solar
probes flight let's so let's head over
back over to Josh for the latest Josh
Thank You Marie I'm here again with
Alisa Macbeth and we've been monitoring
the flight as it's gone so far and can
you tell us that about where we are now
and what's about to come up next yeah so
as I mentioned earlier there was - burn
- burns of the second stage so we're
about to come up on that that second
burn after that the engines will light
and we'll enter that that phase and then
they'll cut off and we'll enter into a
Coast phase right before a second stage
separation then the third stage will
ignite at approximately 37 minutes into
the flight and that will be our last and
final burn before spacecraft separation
so we had a great launch on time and
this morning at 3:30 1:00 a.m. but there
but there's still more work to do before
the spacecraft separates and can you
tell me what's what's next
for United Launch Alliance yeah our team
is still working to their monitoring
data in the launch control room and in
Denver as well as here I'm just looking
to make sure everything looks nominal
that the booster performed they're
probably looking at data from the
booster make sure you sure everything
looked looked clear and good there and
as we continue through the flight
they'll continue to do that well once
again you're looking at live telemetry
feed here that's it's an animated feed
that you see of the second stage when
the very top of it you see mass is
parked or Solar Probe there which is
moving toward its separation time and we
just have confirmation of ignition of
the rl10 engine and with that elisa
thank you for joining us today and thank
you for a great launch thank you for
having me again just thanks
body rates continuing to look good
chamber pressure remaining stable 24
minutes five seconds into flight
we are at a mission elapsed time of 24
minutes 50 seconds and to launch the
second burn of the rl10 engine you see
on your screen from the telemetry feed
that is updated in real-time and will
continue to monitor things as we move
towards spacecraft separation where
Parker Solar Probe will then begin to
unfurl its solar wings but for now we'll
go back to Marie Lewis in the studio
Marie
alright thanks Josh the Parker Solar
Probe mission is designed to collect
data and study solar processes that
scientists have never seen before
NASA edges Blair Allen spoke with
Mission system engineer Jim Kinnison
about the unique challenges in
developing this mission Jim tell me what
is the Parker Solar Probe mission so
since the beginning of NASA even there
have been as there's been a desire to
explore the regions around the Sun close
in to the Sun to understand the
processes that are going on there how
the particles coming from the Sun are
accelerated how all that energy goes out
into the solar system and even even to
the earth and beyond
Parker Solar Probe mission is the final
fulfillment of that vision we'll be able
to fly the spacecraft into very close
regions of the Sun make those
fundamental measurements by taking this
approximately 10 foot long spacecraft
and with a nice heat shield on the front
and keep it pointed in the Sun to
protect all of those things that allow
us to make those measurements
why is it taken so long to get a mission
like this together because I know this
is all new technology so there have been
some fundamental technologies that we've
had to develop over the years and there
have been many people working for
decades really to get those technologies
in place some of those are things like
the heat shield some of it is also in
the area of developing the systems we
need to control the spacecraft we're in
those regions
Parker Solar Probe is a very autonomous
system it has to maintain itself without
a lot of help from humans so the ability
to do that in space is really one of
those fundamental technologies we've had
to develop we've also had to develop
things like cooling systems for solar
arrays so that we can power the
spacecraft when we're close to the Sun
and maintain those temperatures and that
allow us to continue to make the
measurements
couldn't you just like use one really
small solar panel for right when you get
close and get all the energy you need
so spread clean enough we actually do
that when we get close to the Sun we
actually take those solar panels and
tuck them behind the shadow of the heat
shield until only the very tips of the
solar array are generating power so it's
essentially that idea yes I should
I should have been an engineer exactly
anyway that's really awesome now I
understand we're going close to the Sun
but but you're not just flying to the
Sun how are how is this mission oriented
to get to the Sun and get those
measurements you're absolutely right
it's um it's actually a fairly
complicated process to get there we'll
be launching at a very large rocket to
give us a lot of Delta V that allows us
to take out a lot of the Earth's angular
momentum so that we can sort of fall
into the Sun but that doesn't get us
there we actually have to do a flyby of
the planet Venus and use a gravity
assist to take more angular momentum out
of the system so that now we can make
that first approach around the Sun we'll
continue to make several more Venus
flybys and every time we do that our
perihelion the closest approach to the
Sun will get closer and closer to that
point where we finally are seeing the
science that we want to see so how long
is the Parker Solar Probe mission it's
about seven years to get the final set
of data that we want to get will be
making 24 passes close to the Sun in
those seven years starting out at about
six months for each orbit and then down
to about three months per orbit by the
time we get to the end of the mission
what happens after seven years I mean do
you are you are you gonna get pulled
into the Sun or or could you operate
beyond that if possible or we will
likely at some point run out of
propellant and propellant is the thing
that allows us to correct for momentum
and for two point two spacecraft once we
run out of propellant the spacecraft
will actually start rotating just
because of the natural forces around the
Sun and the pressure of the sunlight on
the on the spacecraft itself and
surfaces of the spacecraft which are not
supposed to see the Sun will see the Sun
eventually and so that will have all
sorts of effects that we don't really
understand and eventually the spacecraft
will join the the dust cloud around the
Sun see that's why I asked the question
because captain Kurt went around the Sun
and they actually went back in time so I
was just trying to find out if there was
some extracurricular mission op that
that might send you back seven years so
you can get seven more years the data
you had the advantage of having warp
drive we don't have that well you know
something to put in to develop that's
right Josh is standing by with a
representative now from Northrop Grumman
who has a big role in this mission Josh
Thank You Marie and we're sitting here
continuing to monitor the the burn that
we have here before a main engine cutoff
- which is approximately about eight
minutes and 30 seconds away
for the burn of that engine and now I'm
joined by Keating the others from
northrup-grumman Katie can you tell me a
little bit about yourself and what you
do at norther sure I'm a project manager
for the space launch program supporting
this Parker Solar Probe team and can you
tell me what Northrop Grumman's role is
with this launch Northrop Grumman
innovation systems and sector and the
divisions within it have really
supported this mission tip-to-tail
starting with a large composite
structures basically everything white on
the on the vehicle the nozzles the fuel
tanks and certainly what I'm most
familiar with the third stage and right
now you are looking at a live shot there
that's live telemetry that we're getting
the second stage engine continuing to
burn but after that the third stage the
stages will separate and then we'll have
third stage ignition and can you tell me
what is unique about this mission from
nothing crumbing sure every mission has
its own personality and challenges to
overcome this mission in particular the
Sun gives a new element so there's a
couple things to keep in in to take into
consideration the vehicles trajectory is
going very close to the Van Allen belt
and so the engineers had to create some
rad tolerant electronics masks keeping
the vehicle as light as possible so that
it could have the most performance is
certainly a goal and then I'm also told
that this is the first third stage on a
delta 4 heavy so the those are
definitely some unique aspects of this
mission and so can you tell me a little
bit more about this specially designed
third stage sure overall it's about
seven and a half feet long and it weighs
approximately 5,200 pounds
but it includes a star 48 BV solid
rocket motor it includes flight avionics
that's built on our heritage designs
which includes an
on board flight computer with navigation
adapter structures and its own
separation systems and so we're still
continuing to monitor the burn of the
second stage here approximately six
minutes left and that burn and continue
to talk about the upper stage have as
north of government developed upper
stages for missions before we have most
recently with the star 48 bv in 2013
Northrop Reed adopted our Minotaur 4
vehicle we added an upper stage to
create a Minotaur 5 configuration for
the ladee mission that was a that went
to the moon and just last year we had
another Minotaur 4 out of the cape on
over s5 that was a uniquely designed
upper stage for the to perform a
required plane change and once again
you're looking at a live telemetry feed
of the of the spacecraft flying over
flying over the South Africa near the
heart of V stock which is the hbk that
you see on the bottom right of your
screen and so after the this burn
completes we have a couple of events
that are happening pretty quickly can
you tell me about 3rd stage ignition how
long this burn is going to last yes the
the Parker excuse me the star 48 bv
motor burns for about a minute and a
half and it produces over 15,000 pounds
of thrust which is about 20% of the
total velocity of the of this mission
and about 60% of the overall orbital
escape energy as a star 48 flown before
it has most recently on the ladee
mission into 2013 and then also our tax
at 4 mission earlier in 2011 we just
have about four minutes 20 seconds left
in this bird hey Katie can you talk a
little bit more about how Northup
Grumman has has partnered with United
Launch Alliance for this mission we
northrop and ula have a long-standing
relationship that we're very proud of
and it's it's got
it's roles depending on on the mission
sometimes were customer as in the Cygnus
mission to the International Space
Station sometimes were a vendor as in
the large composite structures that we
have provided for this delta 4 heavy
mission and in this case we're very
proud to be a partner with ula at NASA
we have about three minutes 35 seconds
left in this burn of the RL 10 on the
second stage we had an on-time liftoff
at 3:30 1:00 a.m. Eastern on the delta 4
heavy rocket with the additional
Thursdays that we're speaking about now
the second stage continues to fly on its
planned trajectory
and about three minutes remaining in the
burn rl10 chamber pressure continues to
look good second stage fuel and oxidiser
tank pressures remain stable ACS press
bottle also looks good
now passing 35 minutes into flight
and at 35 minutes 35 seconds into flight
approximately two minutes remaining
until amico - at Miko to the second
stage will send a discrete command to
the third stage to begin the
initialization sequence at that point we
should expect to start seeing telemetry
data from the third stage through their
transmitter 20 seconds after separation
of the second and third stage the third
stage will ignite and it will begin it's
89 second burn
proximately one minute remaining till me
go to
and standing back from eco momentarily
and we have Nico main engine cutoff
now passing 38 minutes into flight
third-stage transmitters on
and visual cue there of separation third
stage telemetry
and we have acquisition of third-stage
Salama tree
and we did see ignition on the third
stage seeing chamber pressures seeing
some periodic dropouts of telemetry
now 39 minutes 30 seconds into flight
should be expecting to see third-stage
Bernal momentarily apologize we're still
seeing some periodic dropouts at
third-stage telemetry difficult to make
calls
and at 40 minutes forty seconds into
flight still seeing some telemetry
dropouts from the third stage at this
point the third stage would have
completed the burn and would be turning
to these spacecraft separation burn
attitude on a nominal time line still
looking for some data to confirm that
Delta flight commentary at 41 minutes 56
seconds into flight we are still
experiencing some drop out of third
stage telemetry trying to confirm that
the sequence of events and will provide
updates when that's available
now passing 43 minutes into flight and
per nominal timeline for today's mission
should be expecting to see spacecraft
separation in approximately one minute
and we've been informed that the third
stage is providing data to a ground
station do not have real-time data so we
will provide updates of those events as
they come in from a playback
at 44 minutes 30 seconds into flight
still attempting to confirm occurrence
of events for the third stage phase of
flight and per nominal timeline should
have expected to see spacecraft
separation within the last minute
and you're looking at a live shot there
that Delta Operations Center team
shaking hands
teams in the Delta operation chin are
shaking hands now that you're not
aligned Launch Alliance at mission
control room we have had confirmation of
spacecraft separation
tension on that too would like to crop
the spacecraft has acquired data and we
are working on a playback to get our
third stage confirmation but at this
point spacecraft is happy and
confirmation of spacecraft separation
there you're looking at a live view
inside the Johns Hopkins Applied Physics
Laboratory where teams were just
celebrating and I'm still joined here by
Katie in the evidence of Northrop
Grumman and Katie can you tell me what's
next for Northland Grumman what
congratulations to the entire team best
of best of luck for Parker Solar Probe
the coming up in the fall we've got the
Pegasus icon mission right here in the
Cape we've got the Antares launch in
November out of Wallops Island Virginia
and then next year in April we've got
the ascent booster test here also at the
Cape April of 2019 well thank you very
much for being with us tonight and enjoy
the rest of your day okay thank you for
you
and once again you're looking at a live
view inside the John Hopkins Applied
Physics Laboratory we just had
confirmation of spacecraft separation so
the teams were pretty cheerful pretty
joyful in the room there
we did have an on-time liftoff of the
delta 4 heavy with the additional third
stage this morning at 3:30 1:00 a.m.
Eastern Time
but for now we'll go back to Murray
Lewis in the studio Murray
all right thanks Josh in order to
collect data for this mission
Parker Solar Probe is outfitted with
several sophisticated instrument suites
NASA edges franklin Fitzgerald spoke
with project scientists Nicky Fox about
the diversity of data researchers will
study you're going to be collecting a
lot of science data with Parker Solar
Probe tell us about the instruments
you're going to use to collect that
information so we have a wonderful
payload that was very carefully thought
about and put together to make sure that
we could make all of the measurements
that we really need to do to answer
these groundbreaking science questions
so we have four instrument suites we
have a white light imager which we call
whisper that is going to look around the
side and take images of the solar wind
that is about to impact the spacecraft
and so it's really going to help us kind
of unlock all our other measurements we
have the fields suite that is going to
measure all of the electric and the
magnetic fields that we want to measure
and also any waves any signatures that
happen to be embedded in the solar wind
we have the ISA suite that measures the
high-energy particles so these are the
kind of nasty guys that are associated
with shocks and with flares and coronal
mass ejections and then certainly not
least we have our sweep suite that is
measuring kind of the bulk solar wind
what is coming what is hidden in the
solar wind what are all the different
particle populations what is the
temperature the velocity the density and
so when we put all of those measurements
together we'll be able to answer our
science questions
now these suite of instruments are they
new or these off-the-shelf components
that you used to build a lot of the
instruments are very similar to ones
that have flown before but they are in
very challenging environment you know
for example we have flown radio wave
antennas
on many missions but not when they're
going into three million degree material
we also have an instrument on the front
of the spacecraft I always refer to it
as the bravest instrument because it
takes no shielding no protection from
our amazing heat shield it peeps that
around the side it's a simple instrument
it's a Faraday cup which have flown on
many NASA missions but now we're asking
it to work in this incredible
environment and so it is made with very
exotic materials and even though it's a
simple instrument boy was that a
challenging thing to get achieved talk
to me about the challenge of building
their instrument to work in these
extreme environments one of our biggest
challenges is not even just the heat so
we're in three million degree plasma yes
that's awful and hot and dangerous but
our orbit is very much like the petals
of a flower so we go very close to this
Sun on one side and then we come out
around the orbit of Venus on the other
which means we go very hot and then very
cold now if you think of taking any
material and heating it and cooling it
many times say 24 which is the number of
orbits that we have most of the time it
will change its property or either
become elastic or it'll become brittle
but it won't be the same 24 times later
all of our materials have to be the same
and so finding materials that would
actually be able to withstand these
changes was of course a challenge and
then testing them the Parker Solar Probe
spacecraft will be seeing just less than
about 500 times the amount of Sun we see
here at Earth so 500 Suns in the sky is
what Parker Solar Probe will be
experiencing and so how do you test it
we actually had to build test facilities
just to be able to do this we used
reconditioned IMAX projectors because it
turned out that the light that they put
out is very much like sunlight and so
every single thing about this mission is
challenging well can I go back to the
IMAX projectors what does that look like
how many projectors were what kind of
facility do you construct this this
projector field to do this test so the
original plan for this particular
instrument was to use a solar
furnace simulator in France the problem
there was that it obviously it only
works during the day and it only works
if it's not cloudy and so we couldn't
get long runs to be able to get
continuous hours and hours and hours
worth of data and so they actually
constructed their own test facility so
up at the Smithsonian astrophysics
Observatory in Boston they actually
constructed basically a vacuum chamber
and then they took the six IMAX
projectors and sort of changed them
together and so that that would provide
this the right amount of illumination
with the right amount of scattering
angle for the light the heat and also
firing particles at the same time to be
able to really simulate what that
instrument is going to see when we get
very close to the Sun is there an
opportunity for Parker Solar Probe to
collect any science on its way to Venus
in back to the Sun so our intention is
to have the instruments on it as much as
possible so we will have them on for the
full journey in around the Sun and the
full journey out the only time that we
will not have the instruments on really
is if we're doing a major maneuver on
the spacecraft or if we're sending our
data down when we need all the power to
go into the system that is going to
transmit the data and so we switch off
the instruments during those periods I
often get asked are you going to do
science around Venus and unfortunately
my quick answer is always no because
whenever we are flying past Venus that
is our prime time to get out of coronal
science data down and so the instruments
plan to be off when we do our Venus
flybys there is one later in the in the
mission we actually do seven of them
there is one when the instruments can be
on and we are excited about what kind of
science we'll be able to do then but
that's a number of years away and a few
days away from launch everybody's
focusing on the on the launch right now
we go before for the launch itself I
will be honestly as close as physically
possible to the delta 4 heavy but in
reality I will be somewhere around the
press building probably looking through
my fingers at at the sight of the the
l/24 heavy but actually if they let me
light it I would I'm sure it's taken us
60 years to get through technological
advances that will get us ready to
launch Parker Solar Probe to the Sun as
you saw a little bit earlier and here's
why it won't melt as it flies through
the Sun's corona to explore the Sun how
can I do that why won't the spacecraft
melt excellent question
you can't face off with the Sun without
packing the right gear this is why Solar
Probe is equipped with a white shield
that reflects heat off the front and
keeps things cool in the back the heat
shield is made out of a couple of
different materials one is carbon carbon
which is a lot like the graphite epoxy
you might see in your golf clubs or your
tennis racket but it's just been
superheated the inside is a carbon foam
which is just another form of carbon and
is actually about 97% air it's a very
lightweight way of making a very strong
structure nobody likes a needy Explorer
Solar Probe can take care of itself
thank you very much and that's because
it has autonomy software that will keep
its instruments safe and cool behind the
heat shield we're too far away to
joystick it into place so it basically
has to always be sensing whether or not
the heat shield is in the right position
and correct itself if it isn't there are
these things called solar limb sensors
that are just poking out at the very
edge of the shadow and if those get
illuminated the spacecraft nose oh I'm
you know going the wrong direction and
can actually write itself it's important
to stay hydrated in the Sun even for a
spacecraft Solar Probe circulates water
to keep the solar cells from overheating
it stays cool and keeps power so
basically water flows behind the solar
rays and into the radiators and so the
water warms up one that's behind the
solar cells and then cools down up at
the radiators and so that heat transfer
is happening a lot like the veins in
your body
[Music]
yes you read right heat is not the same
as temperature temperature is a
measurement but heat is energy transfer
this matters because Solar Probe will be
visiting the sun's outer layer the
corona like all stars the Sun is made of
plasma how tightly packed that plasma is
depends on the layer while the Sun's
corona has a very high temperature the
plasma particles are fairly spread out
so even though the temperature in the
corona is two to three million degrees
Fahrenheit
the heat around the spacecraft is
manageable the corona and where we're
going is actually not that dense at all
they're only a couple particles and so
when we think about it those are very
hot but we're not touching a lot of them
it's the kind of like when you put your
hand into an oven and the oven might be
it for five under view staring high but
your hand isn't at four hundred five
hundred degrees Fahrenheit thanks to its
design and destination this cool
confident spacecraft is all set to
explore we can just sit back and chill
as Parker's Solar Probe takes the heat
[Music]
we are now approaching solar array
deploy or when Parker Solar Probe will
spread its wings let's go back to Josh
in the mission director center to walk
us through this next event Josh Thank
You Murray and we are at a mission
elapsed time of about 58 minutes and 10
seconds and as you mentioned we are
waiting for solar array deployed that
could happen as early as 12 minutes
after spacecraft separation that's a
live shot everyone gathered around
inside that Johns Hopkins Applied
Physics Laboratory we are standing by
for an interview with NASA's launch
manager Omar Baez he's going to talk
more about this mission and how things
went tonight so we'll wait not only for
solar deploy but also to hear from
tonight's NASA launch manager
I am now being joined by the NASA launch
manager Omar Baez Omar can you tell us
how the mission went tonight how the
count went so the count went splendid
today very boring which is awesome for
this kind of launch you know we had a
tough day yesterday and weren't able to
get off in the allotted time that we had
and today just one completely opposite
of it very quiet all day and virtually
had no anomalies to work and the weather
cooperated with us and it went off like
clockwork can you tell me the importance
of the Parker Solar Probe mission to LSB
launch service program so it's very
important it's been one of our most
difficult and challenging missions today
in our 20-year history we've been
through some challenging ones and I
think this one tops the list on the
scale of technical challenges this this
one said and I'm very proud of the team
that worked to make this happen
and we made it happen with a very short
window at the very end for us on a
vehicle a very powerful vehicle flying a
new avionics system and it just
phenomenal to see that delta 4 heavy
takeoff today and we were as close as
you can get to it as possible the energy
of that vehicle the immense size and
when you realize just how tiny the
parker Solar Probe satellite is and you
have this big vehicle around it it's
just mind-boggling it was really nice to
hear Torrey McClendon interview dr.
Parker and he mentioned there are a
couple of icons in the world and one of
them being the Taj Mahal and until you
see it up close you can't believe how
big and beautiful and for real that
thing is well I can say the same thing
about the Delta 4 heavy until you see it
and you see it
clothes you just can't believe it and
when you do it's just a miracle of
technology and we at NASA and the launch
services program are thrilled to be part
of this mission and it's been a busy
year so far for NASA LSB and can you
tell us what you have coming up next so
yeah it's a very busy year we started
six missions this year inside of a short
period of time we do have two missions
remaining this year the ice at mission
on the very last Delta 2 out of
Vandenberg Air Force Base and we look
forward to transitioning the team as
soon as they get a night's rest over to
Vandenberg so they could do a mission
dress rehearse or a mission a cruiser
which is the tanking test of the Delta 2
this coming Wednesday in preparation for
launch of the icesat-2 mission on
September 15 well no more thank you very
much for being with us tonight it was a
beautiful launch and we did receive
confirmation that the solar arrays had
fully extended
so with that Murray will now go back to
you in the studio thank you all right
thank you so much Josh this concludes
our live coverage of the launch of
Parker Solar Probe to learn the secrets
of the sun's atmosphere and help protect
our assets in space for more information
about the Parker Solar Probe mission
visit nasa.gov i'm marine lewis from all
of us here at Kennedy Space Center thank
you for joining us this early Sunday
morning we will leave you now with
replays of Parker's launch to touch the
Sun have a great day Rosi ignition
ten nine eight seven six five three two
one zero
liftoff of the mighty delta 4 heavy
rocket with NASA's Parker Solar Probe a
daring mission to shed light on the
mysteries of our closest star the Sun